almost since the dawn of civilization
cash cash money has been a critical
piece of the world's economy in ancient
times people use gold and silver coins
so they paper money remains the single
most popular way to make transactions in
this country but should it be some
economists say day to day shopping can
easily be done electronically while the
continued use of cash hurts the economy
and may even cause crime Kenneth Rogoff
is a Harvard professor a former chief
economist at the International Monetary
Fund a famous chess player he says it's
time to move forward toward a cashless
society professor Rogoff joins us
tonight professor thanks coming up thank
you for having me so I've heard this
argument before and I understand and I
take seriously the inefficiencies of
cash and the possibilities for crime
transnational crime it avails to
criminals I get all that but there's
also a suspicion that a lot of us have
that eliminating it would just increase
government power maybe to a point that's
dangerous is that a concern for you
absolutely so I actually don't favor
getting rid of cash my favorite getting
rid of large bills like the 50 and 100
and similar around the world I think if
you look at the use of cash actually by
quantity of transactions it's nowhere
near the most popular it's fallen out
it's behind for purchases over you know
$50 it's behind you know debit cards
credit cards electronic payments but for
small payments it's very convenient and
of course sometimes somebody wants to do
something for five thousand even a
hundred thousand dollars they don't want
anyone to know but you know you can
carry a suitcase of $10 bills a
briefcase of $10 bills $100,000 20
pounds if you have to do that once in a
while we shouldn't go cashless but I do
think if you look at the declining use
of cash and the rising printing of these
big bills we ought to realize it's for
tax evasion that's much bigger than
crime and crime and if you can cut back
on tax evasion you could for example
lower tax rates
so you do acknowledge though it sounds
like you are acknowledging that people
have an inherent instinctive desire for
privacy they don't necessarily want
anybody whether it's a bank or the
Treasury Department tracking what
they're doing with their money and
that's okay
you think yeah well okay there's a big
difference between somebody doing a
wholesale business where they're doing
fifty thousand a hundred thousand
dollars in transactions every week and
they don't want the government to know
and you know somebody who's doing
something on a much smaller scale and I
think these wholesale transactions are
facilitated by these big bills big you
know drug kingpins tax evasion is a huge
thing so I just think we need to
recalibrate it a little bit not so much
eliminate it are you worried about the
vulnerabilities of a digital system as
and we're moving in that direction
anyway but I mean the beauty of cash is
it's it's tangible you can hide it under
your bed no one can hack a hundred
dollar bill are you concerned about that
well I'm very concerned about cyber
security on the other hand I think if we
have a problem hanging on to the rump of
cash that we have left in our systems
not going to save us we need to protect
ourselves but yeah that's you know if
you have a big storm that knocks out the
power system
god forbid an EMP blast or something
right it's very useful to have some rump
of cash left there although you know
people been very inventive when that's
happened in the past with checks IOUs
and other things but no no we don't want
to get rid of cash completely but I do
think if you look at you know the what
the government's printing there's almost
pushing over forty five hundred dollars
for every man woman and child in the
United States and there lots of surveys
even if you take the part that's out of
the country the average person is
holding you know maybe a couple hundred
to three hundred counting in their house
counting in their car they're not
holding forty five hundred dollars much
less their kids oh they're not quickly
what do you make of Bitcoin where does
that fall in the spectrum
well I mean bitcoins great innovation
but the part of it that's anonymous
eventually the government has to apply
anti-money laundering rules tax rules
and other things I mean the government
can't just look the other way and let
people do giant transactions
transnational national and not care
about it it's going to get regulated I
think the long run
bitcoins great technology but it's more
likely to look like MySpace that lost
out to Facebook than it is to look like
the next big thing right because it is a
threat to the government in the end and
you never win threatening the government
you in the currency game the government
makes the rules so this idea that you
can invent a currency that wins out it's
it's nonsense it wallet but it's a great
technology that's very uses I love the
idea of it though professor thanks all
for coming on that was interesting thank
you very much for having me